my name is Don Tapscott and I'm sharing
a working group that involves people
from a number of different Global Agenda
councils and the working group is about
how do we solve problems today in the
global economy and in particular what's
the role of new multi-stakeholder
networks that bring together our
governments civil society organizations
private companies and individual
citizens for problem solving no we have
this world that's organized according to
nation stats and these nation states
come together in global institutions
whether the UN or the the WTO or the the
IMF for the the g8 or the g20 and
someone but increasingly these
institutions are having difficulties
solving global problems and what we need
to do is to supplement them with new
internet-enabled collaborations that
involve people across the nation states
and from all walks of society all around
the world would see these sparkling new
initiatives or people who are just
coming together to organize against
climate change to do micro financing to
to solve the problem of irrigation in a
little village in in Africa to come
together to address global financial
problems or two for that matter to think
about how to fix the problems of the
world I mean in some ways the world
economic forum itself is one of these
multi-stakeholder networks are trying to
create a better world and what are
working with us doing is trying to
figure out but let's understand these
things is there a taxonomy to describe
them what makes them tick how do we
address issues like governance and and
legitimacy are these things legitimate
who are they accountable to how do
people get to participate in them is
this is a new terrain of really exciting
issues that will help us make up a
better world hopefully a smaller world
that our kids inherit will be a
we can address these issues